The following is a conversation
with Greg Brockman.
He's the Co founder and Cto of open Ai,
a world class research organization,
developing ideas and AI with a goal of
eventually creating a safe and friendly
artificial general intelligence,
one that benefits and empowers humanity.
Open Ai is not only a source of
publications, algorithms, tools,
and datasets.
Their mission is a catalyst
for an important public
discourse about our future
with both narrow and general
intelligence systems.
This conversation is part of
the artificial intelligence
podcasts at MIT and
beyond. If you enjoy,
subscribe on Youtube, iTunes,
or simply connect with me on Twitter
at Lex Friedman, spelled f, r I. D.
And now here's my conversation
with Greg Brockman.
So in high school, and right after he
wrote a draft of a chemistry textbook,
I saw that that covers everything from
basic structure of the atom to quantum
mechanics. So it's clear you have an
intuition and a passion for both the,
uh,
the physical world with chemistry and
now robotics to the digital world with a
AI deep learning reinforcement learning.
So on.
Do you see the physical world and
the digital world is different?
And what do you think is the gap?
A lot of it actually boils down
to iteration. Speed, right?
That I think that a lot of what really
motivates me is building things right?
Is the, uh, you know, think
about mathematics for example,
where you're thinking
really hard about a problem.
You understand that you're right
down in this period of secure form.
They call it proof. But then this
is in humanities library, right?
It's there forever. This is some truth
that we've discovered and you know,
maybe only five people in
your field will ever read it,
but somehow you've kind
of move humanity forward.
And so I actually used to really think
that I was going to be a mathematician
and a then I actually started
writing this chemistry textbook.
One of my friends told me, you'll never
publish it because you don't have a phd.
So instead I decided to build a website
and try to promote my ideas that way.
And then I discovered
programming. And, uh,
you know that in programming you think
hard about a problem, you understand it,
you're right down in a very obscure
a form that we call a program.
But then once again, it's an
humanities library, right?
And anyone could get the benefit from
it and the scalability is massive.
And so I think that the thing that really
appeals to me about the digital world
is that you can have this, this,
this insane leverage, right?
As single individual with an idea is
able to affect the entire planet. Um,
and that's something I think is really
hard to do if you're moving around
physical atoms.
But you said a mathematics.
So if you look at the,
the wet thing over here,
our mind,
do you ultimately see it as just math
has just information processing or is
there some other magic as you've seen,
if you've seen through biology
and chemistry and so on?
I think it's really interesting to
think about humans as just information
processing systems and that it seems
like it's actually a pretty good way of
describing a lot of,
of kind of how the world works are a lot
of what we're capable of. To think that,
you know, again, if you just look at
technological innovations over time,
that in some ways the most
transformative innovation that we've had,
it has been the computer, right?
In some ways the internet,
you know that what is done right?
The Internet is not about
these physical cables.
It's about the fact that I am suddenly
able to instantly communicate with any
other human on the planet.
I'm able to retrieve any
piece of knowledge that in
some ways the human race has
ever had a, and those are
these insane transformations.
Do you see the
our society as a whole,
the collective as another extension of
the intelligence of the human being.
So if you look at the human beings
and information processing system,
you mentioned the Internet and networking.
Do you see us all together
as a civilization, as a,
as a kind of intelligence system?
Yeah,
I think this is actually a really
interesting perspective have to take in to
think about the, you sort of have this
collective intelligence of all of society.
The economy itself is the
superhuman machine that is
optimizing something, right?
And it's all in some ways a company
has a will of its own right,
that you have all these individuals who
are all pursuing their own individual
goals and thinking really hard and
thinking about the right things to do.
But somehow the company does
something that is this emergent thing.
And that is a really useful abstraction.
And so I think that in some ways,
you know,
we think of ourselves as
the most intelligent things
on the planet and the most
powerful things on the planet,
but there are things that are bigger
than us through the systems that we all
contribute to. Um, and so I
think actually, you know, it's a,
it's interesting to think about, uh, if
you've read Isaac Asimov's foundation,
right, that, uh, that there's this
concept of psycho history in there,
which is effectively this, that if
you have trillions or quadrillions of,
of beings, then maybe you could
actually predict what that being,
that huge macro being we'll do I, and, uh,
almost independent of
what the individuals want.
I actually have a second angle
on this I think is interesting,
which is thinking about
technological determinism.
One thing that actually thinks a
lot about with, with open Ai, right?
It's that we're kind of coming on onto
this insanely transformational technology
of, of general intelligence, right?
That will happen at some point.
And there's a question of how can you
take actions that will actually steer it
to go better rather than worse? And that,
I think one question you need to ask is,
as a scientist, as an inventor,
as a creator, what impact
can you have in general,
right?
You look at things like the telephone
invented by two people on the same day.
Like what does that mean? Like, what does
that mean about the shape of innovation?
And I think that what's going
on is everyone's building
on the shoulders of the
same giants.
And so you can kind of,
you can't really hope to create something
no one else ever would, you know,
if Einstein wasn't born, someone else
would have come up with relativity.
You know, he changed the
timeline a bit, right?
That maybe it would have
taken another 20 years,
but it wouldn't be that fundamentally
humanity would never discover these,
these fundamental truths.
So there's some kind of invisible
momentum that some people like Einstein
or open the eyes plugging into a that
anybody else can also plug into.
And ultimately that wave takes us into
a certain direction. That's for sure.
That's right. That's right. And you know,
this kind of seems to play out
in a bunch of different ways, uh,
that there's some exponential,
it's being written and that
the exponential itself,
which one it is changes,
think about Moore's law
and an entire industry set.
It's cocked to it for 50 years. Like how
can that be? Right? How is that possible?
And yet somehow it happened.
And so I think you can't hope to ever
invent something that no one else will.
Maybe you can change the
timeline a little bit,
but if you really want
to make a difference,
I think that the thing
that you really have to do,
the only real degree of freedom you have
is to set the initial conditions under
which it technology is born. And so
you think about the Internet, right?
That there are lots of other competitors
trying to build similar things and the
Internet one,
and that the initial conditions where
there was created by this group that
really valued people being
able to be, uh, you know,
anyone being able to plug in
this very academic mindset of,
of being open and connected.
And I think that the Internet for the
next 40 years really played out that way.
Um, you know, maybe today, uh, if
things are starting to shift in a,
in a different direction,
but I think that those initial conditions
were really important to determine the
next 40 years worth of progress.
That's really beautifully put.
So another example of that I think about,
you know, I recently looked
at it, I looked at Wikipedia,
the formation of Wikipedia,
and I wonder what the Internet would be
like if Wikipedia had ads. Hmm. You know,
there's an interesting argument that,
uh,
why they chose not to make it a put
advertisement on Wikipedia. I think it's,
uh, I think be, it is one of the greatest
resources we have on the Internet.
It's as assuming surprising how it works
and how all it was able to aggregate
all this kind of good information and the,
essentially the creator Wikipedia.
I don't know,
there's probably some debates there,
but set the initial conditions
and now it carried itself forward.
That's really interesting.
So you're,
the way you're thinking about Agi or
artificial intelligence is you're focused
on setting the initial conditions for the
progress. That's right. That's powerful.
Okay.
So look into the future.
If you create an AGI system like one
that can ace the Turing test natural
language,
what do you think would be the
interactions you would have with it?
What do you think are the
questions you would ask? Like,
what would be the first question you
would ask it her. Him. That's right.
I think that at that point,
if you've really built a powerful system
that is capable of shaping the future
of humanity,
the first question that you really should
ask is how do we make sure that this
plays out well? Um, and so that's actually
the first question that I would ask.
Powerful AGI system.
So you wouldn't ask,
your colleague wouldn't ask like
Eylea you would ask the Gi System, oh,
we've already had the conversation with
Ilya, right? And everyone here. Uh,
and so you want as many perspectives,
uh, a piece of wisdom as you can
before it for answering this question.
So I don't think you necessarily defer
to whatever your powerful system tells
you, but you use it as one input to try
to figure out what to do. But, and I,
I guess fundamentally what it really
comes down to is if you build something
really powerful and you think about it,
think about, for example, the creation of,
uh, of, uh, shortly after the
creation of nuclear weapons, right?
The most important question the world was,
what's the world are going to be like,
how do we set ourselves up in a place
we're going to be able to survive as a
species with Agi? I think the
question slightly different, right?
That there is a question of how do we
make sure that we don't get the negative
effects, but there's also
the positive side, right? You
imagine that, you know, like,
like what won't Agi be like,
like what will be capable of,
and I think that one of the core
reasons that an Agi can powerful and
transformative is actually due to
technological development, right?
If you have something that's capable as
capable as a human and that it's much
more scalable,
uh,
that you absolutely want that thing to
go read the whole scientific literature
and think about how to create
cures for all the diseases, right?
You want it to think about how to go and
build a technologies to help us create
material abundance and to
figure out societal problems
that we have trouble with.
Like how we're supposed to clean
up the environment. And you know,
maybe you want this to go and invent a
bunch of little robots who will go out
and be biodegradable and
turn ocean debris into heart,
harmless molecules. And,
um, I think that that,
that positive side is something that I
think people miss sometimes when thinking
about what an Agi will be like.
Um,
and so I think that if you have a
system that's capable of all of that,
you absolutely want it to advice about
how do I make sure that we're using your,
uh, your kid buildings in a
positive way for humanity.
So what do you think about
that psychology that, uh,
looks at all the different possible
trajectories of an AGI system,
many of which perhaps the majority of
which are positive and nevertheless
focuses on the negative trajectories.
And then you get to interact with folks.
You get to think about this maybe
within yourself as well. Uh,
you look at Sam Harris and so on. It
seems to be, sorry to put it this way,
but almost more fun to think
about the negative possibilities,
whatever that's deepen our psychology.
What do you think about that
and how do we deal with it?
Because we want AI to help us.
So I think there's kind of two
problems entailed in that question.
The first is more of the question of how
can you even picture what a world with
a new technology will be like.
Now,
imagine we're in 1950 and I'm
trying to describe Uber to someone,
apps and the Internet.
Yeah, I mean that's, that's,
that's going to be extremely complicated,
but it's imaginable cool. It's,
it's imaginable, right? But, and now
imagine being in 1950 and predicting Uber,
right? And you need to describe the
Internet. You need described gps.
You need to describe the
fact that everyone's going
to have this phone in their
pocket.
And so I think that that just the first
truth is that it is hard to picture how
a transformative technology
will play out in the world. Um,
we've seen that before with technologies
that are far less transformative than
Agi will be.
And so I think that that one piece is
that it's just even hard to imagine and to
really put yourself in a world
where you can predict what that,
that positive vision would be like.
And you know,
I think the second thing is that it is,
I think it is always easier to support
the negative side than the positive side.
It's always easier to destroy than create
and you know, less than a, in a, in a,
in a physical science and more just in a,
in an intellectual sense, right? Because,
you know,
I think that that with creating something,
you need to just get a bunch
of things right and to destroy,
you just need to get one thing wrong.
Yeah. And so I think that that,
what that means is that I think a lot of
people's thinking dead ends as soon as
they see the negative story.
But that being said,
I actually actually have some
hope, right? I think that the,
that the positive vision is
something that I think can be, uh,
is something that we can,
we can talk about.
And I think that just simply saying this
fact of, yeah, like there's positives,
there's negatives.
Everyone likes to dwell on the negative.
People have to respond well to that
message and say, Huh, you're right.
There's a part of this that we're
not talking about not thinking about.
And that's actually something that's,
that's that's I think really been a key
part of how we think about Agi at open
Ai. Right. You can kind of look
at it is like, okay, like opening,
I talks about the fact that there are
risks and yet they're trying to build this
system.
Like how do you square those two facts?
So do you share the intuition
that some people have a,
I mean from Sam Harris to
even Elon Musk himself,
that it's tricky as you develop Agi
to keep it from slipping into the
existential threats into the negative.
What's your intuition about?
How hard is it to keep AI development
on the positive track and your intuition
there to, to answer the question, you can
really look at how we structure open Ai.
So we really have three main
arms that we have capabilities,
which is actually doing the technical
work and pushing forward what these
systems can do if there's safety,
which is working on technical mechanisms
to ensure that the systems we build are
aligned with human values.
And then there's policy,
which is making sure that we
have governance mechanisms
answering that question
of well,
whose values?
And so I think that the technical safety
one is the one that people kind of talk
about the most, right? You talked
about like think about, you know,
all of the just topic AI movies.
A lot of that is about not having
good technical safety in place. Um,
and what we've been finding is that,
you know,
I think that actually a lot of people
look at the technical safety problem and
think it's just intractable,
right?
This question of what do humans want?
How am I supposed to write that down?
Can I even write down what I want?
No Way. And then they stopped there.
But the thing is we've already built
systems that are able to learn things that
humans can't specify.
You know,
even the rules for how to recognize
if there's a cat or a dog in an image,
but it turns out it's intractable to write
that down and yet we're able to learn
it.
And that what we're seeing with systems
we built at open AI and they're still in
early proof of concept stage is that
you are able to learn human preferences.
You're able to learn what
humans want from data. Um,
and so that's kind of the core
focus for our technical safety team.
And I think that they're actually,
we've had some pretty encouraging updates
in terms of what we've been able to
make work. So you have an
intuition in a hope that from data,
you know, looking at the value
alignment problem from data,
we can build systems that align with the
collective better angels of our nature.
So align with,
um,
the ethics and the morals of human beings
to even say this in a different way.
I mean, think about how
do we align humans, right?
Think about like a human baby can grow up
to be an evil person or a great person.
And a lot of that is from
learning from data, right?
That you have some feedback
as a child is growing up,
they get to see positive examples.
And so I think that that just like the,
the only example we have of a general
intelligence that is able to learn from
data I to aligned with human
values and to learn values, um,
I think we shouldn't be surprised that
we can do the same sorts of techniques or
whether the same sort of techniques end
up being how we saw value alignment for
Agi Gis. So let's go even
a highest, I don't know if
you've read the book Sapiens,
but uh, there's an idea
that, you know, um,
that as a collective as us human beings
who kind of developed together and ideas
that we hold, there is no in
that context, objective truth,
we just kind of all agree to certain
ideas and hold them as a collective.
Did you have a sense that there
is and the world of good and evil?
Do you have a sense that to the first
approximation there are some things that
are good and that we could teach
systems to behave to be good.
So I think that this actually
blends into our third team, right?
Which is the policy team. And this is
the one, the, the aspect that he'd,
people really talk about weigh
less than they should, right?
Because imagine that we built super
powerful systems that we've managed to
figure it all of the mechanisms for
these things to do whatever the operator
wants. The most important question
becomes who's the operator,
what do they want and how is that
going to affect everyone else? Right.
And I think that this question of
what is good, what are those values?
I mean I think you, you don't
even have to go to those, those,
those very grand exit central places to
start to realize how hard this problem
is. You just look at different countries
and cultures across the world, right?
And that there's, there's a very different
conception of how the world works.
And you know, what, what, what kinds
of ways that society wants to operate.
And so I think that that the, that
the really core question is, is, is,
is actually a very concrete,
um,
and I think it's not a question that
we have ready answers to, right,
is how do you have a world where all
of the different countries that we have
United States, China, Russia,
and you know, the, the, the,
the hundreds of other countries out
there are able to continue to not just
operate in the way that, that the,
that they see fit. But in, in, uh,
the world that emerges in these were
where you have these very powerful systems
operating alongside humans ends up being
something that empowers humans more,
that makes like exist human existence
be a more meaningful thing and a,
that people are happier and wealthier and,
uh, able to live more fulfilling lives.
It's not an obvious thing for how to
design that world once you have that very
powerful system.
So if
take a little step back and we're having
it like a fascinating conversation and
a opening, as in many ways
a tech leader in the world.
And yet we're thinking about
these big existential questions,
which is fascinating,
really important.
I think you're a leader in that space
and it's a really important space of just
thinking how AI affects society in a, in
a big picture view. So Oscar Wilde said,
we're all in the gutter,
but some of us are looking at the stars
and I think open AI has a charter that
looks to the stars, I would
say, to create intelligence,
to create general intelligence, make
it beneficial, safe, and collaborative.
Can you tell me
how that came about?
How a mission like that and the path to
creating a mission like that open? Yeah,
I was founded.
Yeah. So I think that in some ways it
really boils down to taking a look at the
landscape, right? So if you
think about the history of Ai,
that basically for the
past 60 or 70 years,
people have thought about those goal of
what could happen if you could automate
human intellectual labor. Right? Okay.
Imagine you can build a computer
system that could do that.
What becomes possible.
We have a lot of Scifi that tells stories
of various dystopias and you know,
increasingly you have movies like heard
that tell you a little bit about maybe
more of a little bit utopic vision.
You think about the impacts that we've
seen from being able to have bicycles for
our minds and computers. Uh, and
that I think that the impact of,
of computers and the Internet has just
far outstripped what anyone really could
have predicted. And so I think that it's
very clear that if you can build an Agi,
it will be the most transformative
technology that humans will ever create.
And so what it boils down to then is
a question of, well, is there a path?
Is there hope?
Is there a way to build such a system?
And I think that for 60 or 70 years
that people got excited and, uh, uh,
that ended up not being able to deliver
on the hopes that the people had pinned
on them. And I think that then, you
know, that after, you know, two,
two winters of Ai Development,
uh, that people, uh, you know,
I think kind of almost stopped
daring to dream, right?
That they really talking about Agi or
thinking about Agi became almost this
taboo in the community.
But I actually think that people took
the wrong lesson from AI history.
And if you look back, starting in 1959
is when the perceptron was released.
And this is basically, you know,
one of the earliest neural networks.
It was released to what was
perceived as this massive overhype.
So in the New York Times in 1959 and you
have this article saying that, you know,
the,
the perceptron will one day recognize,
people call it their names instantly
translate speech between languages.
And people at the time looked at this
and said, this is, check your system,
can't do any of that.
And basically spent 10 years trying to
discredit the whole perceptron direction
and succeeded and all the funding dried
up and you know, people kind of, uh,
went in other directions and you know,
the 80s,
there's a resurgence and I'd always heard
that the resurgence in the 80s was due
to the invention of
backpropagation and these,
these algorithms that got people excited,
but actually the causality was due to
people building larger computers that you
can find these,
these articles from the 80 [inaudible]
that the democratization of computing
power suddenly meant that you could run
these larger neural networks and then
people start to do all
these amazing things.
Backpropagation algorithm was
invented and you know that the,
the neural nets people were running
were these tiny little like 20 near on
neural nets. Right? Right. Like what are
you supposed to learn with 20 neurons?
And so of course,
they weren't able to get great results
and it really wasn't until 2012 that this
approach,
that's almost the most simple natural
approach that people would come up with in
the fifties. Right? In some ways,
even in the forties before there were
computers with the pits mackolen there in
neuron,
suddenly this became the best
way of solving problems, right?
And I think there are three
core properties that deep
learning has that I think
are very worth paying attention to.
The first is generality.
We have a very small number of deep
learning tools, SGD deep neural net,
maybe some, some, you know RL and it
solves this huge variety of problems.
Speech recognition, machine
translation, game playing,
all of these problems since small set
of tools. So there's the generality,
there's a second piece,
which is the competence you want to
solve any of those problems, throw it.
40 years worth of normal computer vision
research replaced with a deep neural
net. It's kind of worked better.
And there's a third piece,
which is the scalability,
right?
That one thing that has been shown
time and time again is that you,
if you have a larger neural network,
throw more compute, more data at it,
it will work better.
Those three properties together feel like
essential parts of building a general
intelligence. Now, it doesn't just
mean that if we scale up what we have,
that we will have an Agi, right?
They're clearly missing pieces.
They're missing ideas.
We need to have answers for reasoning.
But I think that the core here is that
for the first time it feels that we have
a paradigm that gives us hope that
general intelligence can be achievable.
And so as soon as you
believe that everything else
becomes, it comes into focus,
right?
If you imagine that you may be able to,
and you know that the timeline
I think remains uncertain. Um,
but I think that that,
you know,
certainly within our lifetimes
and possibly within a much
shorter period of time
than,
than people would expect.
If you can really build the most
transformative technology will ever exist,
you stop thinking about yourself so much,
right?
And you start thinking about just like
how do you have a world where this goes
well and that you need to think about
the practicalities of how do you build an
organization and get together a
bunch of people and resources, um,
and to make sure that people feel,
uh, motivated and ready to do it.
But I think that then you start thinking
about, well, what if we succeed? Um,
and how do we make sure that when we
succeed that the world is actually the
place that we want ourselves to exist.
And you know,
almost in the Rawlsian bail sense of
the word. And so that's kind of the,
the broader landscape and opening.
I was really formed in 2015 with that
high level picture of Agi might be
possible sooner than
people think. And that, uh,
we need to try to do our best to
make sure it's going to go well.
And then we spent the next couple of years
really trying to figure out what does
that mean, how do we do it?
Um, and you know, I think
that typically with accompany,
you start out very small. So you want
to co founder and you build a product,
do you get some users, you get
product market fit, you know,
then at some point you raise some money,
you hire people, you scale and then, uh,
you know, down the road then the
big companies realize he existed in,
tried to kill you.
Um,
and for open AI it was basically
everything in exactly the opposite order.
Uh,
let me just pause for a second.
You said a lot of things and let me just
admire the jarring aspect of what open
AI stands for, which is a daring to dream.
I mean, you said it's pretty powerful.
It caught me off guard because I
think that's very true. The, the,
the step of just daring to dream
about the possibilities of creating
intelligence in a positive,
in a safe way,
but just even creating intelligence is a,
a much needed refreshing,
a catalyst for the AI community. So
that's, that's the starting point. Okay.
So then formation
an AI, uh, I would just say
that, you know, when we were
starting opening, I, uh,
that kind of the first
question that we had is,
is it too late to start a lab with
a bunch of the best people possible?
That wasn't an actual question.
That was really, that was,
that was the core question of uh, of, you
know, we had this dinner in July of 28,
2015 and was that was,
that was really what we spent the whole
time talking about. And uh, you know,
cause it's,
you think about kind of where AI was,
is that it transition from being an
academic pursuit to an industrial pursuit.
And so a lot of the best people were
in these big research labs and that we
wanted to start our own one that,
you know,
no matter how much resources we could
accumulate would be no pale in comparison
to the big tech companies.
And we knew that and there was a question
of are we going to be actually able to
get this thing off the ground?
You need critical mass.
You can't just do you and a
cofounder build the product, right?
You really need to have a group of,
you know, five to 10 people. And uh,
we kind of concluded it wasn't obviously
impossible. Uh, so it seems worth trying.
Well, you were also dreamers, so who
knows, right? That's right. Okay.
So this is speaking of that competing
with, with the, with the big players.
Um,
let's talk about some of the,
some of the tricky things as you
think through this process of growing,
of, uh, seeing how you can develop these
systems at USC at scale that competes.
So you recently,
recently formed Openai LP and you cap
profit company and now carries the name
open as open as now this official company,
the original nonprofit company still
exists and carries the open AI nonprofit
name.
So can you explain what this company is,
what the purpose of his is
and how did you arrive at the decision?
Yup.
To create it open Ai,
the whole entity and opening I LP as
a vehicle is trying to accomplish the
mission of ensuring that artificial
general intelligence benefits everyone.
And the main way that we're trying to
do that is by actually trying to build
general intelligence ourselves and make
sure the benefits are distributed to the
world. That's the primary way. We're also
fine if someone else does this right?
It doesn't have to be us if someone else
is going to build an Agi and make sure
that the benefits don't get knocked up
in one company or you know, one, one,
one with one set of people, um,
like we're actually fine with that.
And so those ideas are
baked into our charter,
which is kind of the
foundational document that are,
describes kind of our values
and how we operate. Um,
it was also really baked into
the structure of open ILP.
And so the way that we've set up
opening ILP is that in the case where we
succeed, right? If we actually
build what we're trying to build,
then investors are able to get a return.
And that return is something that is kept.
And so if you think of Agi in terms of
the value that you could really create,
you're talking about the most
transformative technology ever created.
It's going to create orders of magnitude
more value than any existing company,
and that all of that value
will be owned by the world,
like legally titled to the nonprofit
to fulfill that mission. And so that's,
that's the structure.
So the mission is a
powerful one and it's a,
it's one that I think most
people would agree with.
It's how we would hope AI progresses.
And so how do you tie
yourself to that mission?
How do you make sure you did not
deviate from that mission that, um,
you know, other incentives that
are profit driven wouldn't,
don't interfere with the mission.
So th this was actually a
really core question for us, uh,
for the past couple of years because,
you know,
I'd say that like the
way that our history,
when was that for the first year we
were getting off the ground, right?
We had this high level picture,
but we didn't know exactly how we
want it to accomplish it. And, uh,
it really two years ago is when we first
started realizing in order to build Agi,
we're just going to need to raise way
more money than we can as a nonprofit. Um,
and you are talking many
billions of dollars.
And so the first question is how are
you supposed to do that and stay true to
this mission?
And we looked at every legal structure
out there and concluded none of them are
quite right for what we wanted to do.
And I guess it shouldn't be too surprising
if you're going to do something like
crazy,
unprecedented technology that you're going
to have to come up with some crazy on
precedent and structure to
do it in. And a, a lot of,
a lot of our conversation was, uh,
with people at opening, I right,
the people who really joined because
they believe so much in this mission and
thinking about how do we actually raise
the resources to do it and also stay
true to what we stand for.
And the place you got to start is to
really align on what is it that we stand
for? What are those values?
What's really important to us.
And so I'd say that we spent about a year
really compiling the opening I charter
and that determines,
and if you even look at the first,
the first line item in
there, it says that, look,
we expect we're going to have to
marshal huge amounts of resources,
but we're going to make sure that we
minimize conflict of interest with the
mission.
And that kind of aligning on all of
those pieces was the most important step
towards figuring out how do we structure
a company that can actually raise the
resources to do what we need to do.
I imagine open Ai,
uh,
the decision to create open a
LP was a really difficult one.
And there was a lot of discussions
as you mentioned for a year and, uh,
there's different ideas perhaps
to tractors within open AI,
uh, sort of different paths that you could
have taken. What were those concerns?
What were the different paths considered?
What was that process of making
that decision like? Yup. Um,
but so if you look actually at the
opening I charter that there's almost two
paths embedded within it.
There is,
we are primarily trying
to build AGI ourselves,
but we're also okay if someone else
does it and this is a weird thing for a
company. It's really interesting
actually. Yeah, there,
there is an element of competition that
you do want to be the one that does it,
but at the same time you,
okay,
somebody has us and we'll talk about
that a little bit. That trade off.
That's the dance. That's really
interesting and I think this was the
core tension as we were designing opening
I LP and really the opening I strategy
is how do you make sure that both you
have a shot at being a primary actor,
which really requires
building an organization,
raising massive resources and really
having the will to go and execute on some
really, really hard vision. Right?
You need to really sign up for a long
period to go and take on a lot of pain and
a lot of risk.
And to do that,
normally you just import the startup
mindset, right? And that you think about,
okay, like how do we out execute
everyone if this very competitive angle.
But you also have the second
angle of saying that, well,
the true mission isn't
for open AI to build AGI.
The true mission is for Agi
to go well for humanity.
And so how do you take all of those first
actions and make sure you don't close
the door on outcomes that would actually
be positive and fulfill the mission?
And so I think it's a very
delicate balance, right?
And I think that going 100% one direction
and the other is clearly not the
correct answer.
And so I think that even in terms of
just how we talk about open AI and think
about it,
there's just like,
one thing that's always in the back of
my mind is to make sure that we're not
just saying open your eyes
goal is to build Agi, right?
That it's actually much broader than that,
right? That first of all, uh, you know,
it's not just Agi, it's safe Agi,
that's very important. But secondly,
our goal isn't to be the ones to build it.
Our goal is to make sure
it goes well for the world.
And so I think that figuring out how do
you balance all of those, um, and to,
to get people to really come to
the table and compile the, the,
like a single document that that
encompasses, all of that wasn't trivial.
So part of the challenge here is a,
your mission is,
I would say beautiful,
empowering and a beacon of hope for
people in the research community and just
people thinking about Ai.
So your decisions are scrutinized more
than I think a regular profit driven
company.
Do you feel the burden of this in the
creation of the chart and just in the way
you operate? Yes. Uh,
so why do you lean into the
burden by creating such a charter?
Why not to keep it
quiet? I mean, it's just
boils down to the, to
the mission, right? Like,
like I'm here and everyone else was
here because we think this is the most
important mission,
right? To dare to dream.
All right. So, uh,
do you think you can be good for the
world or create an AGI system that's good
when you're a for profit company?
From my perspective,
I don't understand why profit,
uh,
interferes with a positive
impact on society.
I don't understand, uh, why, uh,
Google it makes most of its money from
ads can't also do good for the world or
other companies, Facebook,
anything. I don't,
I don't understand why those have to
interfere. You know, that you can, um,
profit isn't the thing in my view
that affects the impact of a company.
What affects the impact of the company
is the charter, is the culture,
is the, you know, the people inside.
And profit is the thing that
just fuels those people. So what,
what are your views there?
Yeah, so I think it's a really
good question. And there's,
there's, there's some,
some,
you know,
real like long standing debates in human
society that are wrapped up in it. Uh,
the way that I think about
it is just think about what,
what are the most impactful
nonprofits in the world?
What are the most impactful for
profits in the world? Right?
It's much easier to list the four profits.
That's right. And I think that there's,
there's some real truth year that the
system that we set up the system for kind
of how, you know, today's
world is organized, um,
is one that that really allows for huge
impact. Um, and that the, you know,
kind of part of that is that you need to
be the, you know, for, for profits are,
are self sustaining and able to, to kind
of, you know, build on their own momentum.
And I think that's a
really powerful thing.
It's something that when it turns out
that we haven't set the guardrails
correctly causes problems,
right?
Think about logging companies that
go into the forest, the rain forest,
that's really bad. We don't want that. Um,
and it's actually really
interesting to me that kind of this,
this question of how do you get positive
benefits out of a for profit company.
It's actually very similar to how do you
get positive benefits out of an Agi. Um,
right? That you have this
like very powerful system.
It's more powerful than any human and
it's kind of autonomous in some ways.
You know,
it's super superhuman in a lot of axes.
And somehow you have to set the guard
rails to get good things to happen.
But when you do, the benefits are
massive. And so I think that that when,
when I think about
nonprofit versus for profit,
I think just not enough happens
in nonprofits. They're very pure,
but it's just kind of, you know, it's
just hard to do things there, um,
in for profits in some ways like
too much happens. Um, but, um, if,
if kind of shaped in the right way,
it can actually be very positive.
And so with opening NLP, we're,
we're picking a road in between. Now,
the thing I think is really important to
recognize is that the way that we think
about opening Ilp is that in the world
we're Agi actually happens, right?
In a world where we are successful,
we built the most
transformative technology ever.
The amount of value we're going
to create will be astronomical.
And so then in that case that the,
the,
the cap that we have will be a small
fraction of the value we create. Um,
and the amount of value that goes
back to investors and employees,
it looks pretty similar
to what would happen in a,
in a pretty successful startup.
And that's really the case that
we're optimizing for, right?
That we're thinking about
and the success case,
making sure that the value we create,
it doesn't get locked up.
And I expected in another,
you know,
for profit companies that it's
possible to do something like that.
I think it's not obvious
how to do it right.
And I think that as a for profit company,
you have a lot of fiduciary duty to your
shareholders and that there are certain
decisions that you just cannot
make. Um, in our structure,
we've set it up so that we have a
fiduciary duty to the charter, right?
That we always get to make the decision
that is right for the charter, um,
rather than even if it comes at the
expense of our own stakeholders and a,
and so I think that when I think
about what's really important,
it's not really about
nonprofit versus for profit.
It's really a question of if you build
the Gi and you kind of, you know,
communities now and this new age who
benefits, whose lives are better.
And I think that what's really important
is to have an answer that is everyone.
Yeah. Which is one of the core aspects of
the charter. So one concern people have,
not just with open AI but with
Google, Facebook, Amazon, anybody,
uh, really, uh, that's, uh,
that's creating impact at
scale is how do we avoid,
as your charter says,
avoid enabling the use of AI or
Agi to unduly concentrate power.
Why would not accompany like open AI,
keep all the power of [inaudible] system
to itself, the charter, the charter. So,
you know,
how does the charter actualize
itself in a day to day?
So I think that the first
two to zoom out right there,
the way that we structured
the company so that the,
the power first sort of
dictating the actions,
that opening I takes ultimately
respite the board or the board of, of,
of the nonprofit. Um, and,
and the board is set up in certain ways
with certain certain restrictions that
you can read about in the
opening I LP blog posts.
But effectively the board is the, is the
governing body for opening Openai LP.
Um, and the board has a duty to
fulfill the mission of the nonprofit.
Um, and so that's kind of how we tie
how we all these things together.
Now there's a question of,
so day to day, how do people,
the individuals who in ways are the most
empowered ones right now the board sort
of gets to call the
shots at the high level,
but the people who were actually
executing are the employees, right?
The people here on a day to day
basis who have the, you know, the,
the keys to the technical all kingdom.
And there,
I think that the answer looks a lot like,
well,
how does any company's
values get actualized? Right?
And I think that a lot of that comes
down to do you need people who are here
because they really believe
in that mission and they
believe in the charter and
that they are willing to take actions
that maybe our worst for them but are
better for the charter.
Um,
and that's something that's really
baked into the culture. And honestly,
I think it's, uh, you know,
I think that that's one of the things
that we really have to work to preserve as
time goes on.
Um,
and that's a really important part of
how we think about hiring people and
bringing people into open Ai.
So there's people here,
there's people here who
could speak up and say like,
hold on a second.
This is totally against what we stand
for a culture wise. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I mean, I think that, uh, that
we actually have, I think a,
that's like a pretty important part of,
of how we operate and how we have,
even again,
with designing the charter and,
and designing open LP in the first place,
uh,
that there has been a lot of
conversation with employees here.
And a lot of times where employee said,
wait a second,
this seems like it's going in the wrong
direction and let's talk about it.
And so I think one thing that's, that's
I think a really, and you know, here's,
here's actually one thing that I think
is very unique about us as a small
company is that if you're at a massive
tech giant that's a little bit hard for
someone who's aligned employee to
go and talk to the CEO and say,
I think that we're doing
this wrong. Um, and you know,
you look at companies like Google that
have had some collective action from
employees to, you know, make, uh,
ethical change around things like maven.
And so maybe there are mechanisms that
are other companies that work. Um,
but here super easy for anyone to pull
me aside to pull Sam aside to lily aside
and people do it all the time.
One of the interesting things in the
charter is this idea that it'd be great if
you could try to describe or untangle
switching from competition to
collaboration in late stage Agi
development. It was really interesting.
This dance between competition
and collaboration. How
do you think about that?
Yeah. Assuming that you can actually do
the technical side of Agi Development,
I think there's going to be two key
problems with figuring out how do you
actually deploy it,
make it go well.
The first one of these is the
runup to building the first AGI.
You look at how self driving cars are
being developed and it's a competitive
race. And the thing that always happens
in competitive race is that you have huge
amounts of pressure to get rid of safety.
And so that's one thing we're very
concerned about, right, is that people,
multiple teams figuring out,
we can actually get there,
but you know,
if we took the slower path that is more
guaranteed to be safe, we will lose.
And so we're going to take the fast path.
And so the more that we can both
ourselves be in a position where we don't
generate that competitive race where we
say if the race is being run and that
you know, someone else's is further ahead
than we are, we're not going to try to,
to leap frog, we're going to
actually work with them. Right?
We will help them succeed.
As long as what they're trying to do is
to fulfill our mission, then we're good.
We don't have to build AGI ourselves.
Um,
and I think that's a really
important commitment from us.
But it can't just be you unilateral,
right.
I think it's really important that other
players were serious about building Agi,
make similar commitments. Right.
And I think that that, again,
to the extent that everyone believes
that Agi should be something to benefit
everyone, then it actually really
shouldn't matter which company builds it.
And we should all be concerned about the
case where we just raced so hard to get
there. Then something goes wrong. So
what role do you think government,
our favorite entity has in setting
policy and rules about this domain?
From research to the development?
To too early stage to late
stage AI and Agi development.
So I think that first of
all, um, is really important
that governments in there,
right in some way,
shape or form. You know,
at the end of the day we're talking
about Olin technology that will shape how
the world operates and that there needs
to be government as part of that answer.
And so that's why we've, uh, we've,
we've done a number of different
congressional testimonies. We, uh,
interact with a number of different
lawmakers. Uh, and, uh, you know,
right now a lot of our message to them
is that it's not the time for regulation.
It is the time for measurement that
our main policy recommendation is that
people, and you know, the government does
this all the time with bodies like nest.
Um, spend time trying to figure
out just where the technology is,
how fast it's moving,
and can really become literate and up
to speed with respect to what to expect.
Um, so I think that today
the answer really is about,
about, about measurement. Um,
and I think that there will be a time and
place where that will change. And, uh,
I think it's a little bit
hard to predict exactly what,
what exactly that
trajectory should look like.
So there will be a point
at which regulation federal
in the United States the
government steps in and helps be the,
I don't want to say the adult in the
room to make sure that there is strict
rules, maybe conservative
rules that nobody can cross.
Oh, well I think there's,
there's kind of maybe two,
two angles to it.
So today with narrow AI applications
that I think there are already existing
bodies that are responsible and
should be responsible for regulation.
You think about it, for example, with
self driving cars that you want the, uh,
you know, the national highway, I Nitsa
exactly. To, to be very good and that,
that makes sense, right? The,
basically what we're saying is that
we're going to have these technological
systems that are going to be performing
applications that humans already do.
Great. We already have ways of thinking
about standards and safety for those. Um,
so I think it actually empowering
those regulators today is also pretty
important. And then I think
for, for Agi, you know,
that there's going to be a point
where we'll have better answers.
And I think that maybe a similar approach
of first measurement and you know,
start thinking about what
the rules are should be.
I think it's really important that we
don't prematurely squash, you know,
progress. I've got to get very easy
to kind of smother the abutting field.
And I think that's
something to really avoid.
But I don't think it's the
right way of doing it is to say,
let's just try to blaze ahead and not
involve all of these other stakeholders.
So,
uh,
you've recently released a paper on
a gpt to language modeling, uh, uh,
but,
uh,
did not release the full model because
he had concerns about the possible
negative effects of the
availability of such model.
It's a outside of just that decision.
It's super interesting because of the
discussion as at a societal level,
the discourse it creates.
So it's fascinating in that aspect.
But if you think it's the
specifics here at first,
what are some negative effects
that you envisioned? And of course,
what is some of the positive effects?
Yeah, so again, I think to zoom out,
like the way that we thought about gpt
too is that with language modeling,
we are clearly on a trajectory right now
where we scale up our models and we get
qualitatively better performance,
right?
Gpt to itself was actually just a scale
up of a model that we've released in the
previous June,
right?
And we just ran it at a much larger
scale and we got these results where if
suddenly starting to write coherent pros,
uh,
which was not something
we'd seen previously. And
what are we doing now? Well,
we're going to scale up GPD two by 10 x
by a hundred acts by thousand decks and
we don't know what we're going to get.
And so it's very clear that the model
that we, that we released last June,
you know, I think it's kind of like, it's,
it's, it's, it's a good academic toy.
It's not something that we think is
something that can really have negative
applications or you know,
to the extent that a candidate,
the positive of people being able to
play with it, uh, is, is you know,
far far outweighs the,
the possible harms you fast
forward to not gpt to but you 20.
Okay. And you think about
what that's going to be like.
And I think that the capabilities
are going to be substantive.
And so there needs to be a point
in between the two where you say,
this is something where we are drawing
the line and that we need to start
thinking about the safety aspects.
And I think for GPD too,
we could have gone either
way. And in fact, when we
had conversations internally,
uh, that we had a bunch of pros and
cons, um, and it wasn't clear which one,
which one outweighed the other. Um, and
I think that when we announced that, hey,
we decided not to release this model,
then there was a bunch of conversation
where various people said,
it's so obvious that you
should have just released it.
There are other people said it's so
obvious you should not have released it.
And I think that that almost
definitionally means that
holding it back was the
correct decision, right?
If it's con, if there's,
if it's not obvious whether
something is beneficial or not,
you should probably default to caution.
And so I think that the, that the,
that the overall landscape for how we
think about it is that this decision could
have gone either way. There's
great arguments of both directions,
but for future models down the road,
um,
and possibly sooner than you'd
expect because, you know,
scaling these things up
doesn't have to take that long.
Those ones you're definitely not going
to want to, to release into the wild.
And so,
um,
I think that we almost view this as a
test case and to see can we even design,
you know,
how do you have a society,
how do you have a system that goes
from having no concept of responsible
disclosure,
where the mere idea of not releasing
something for safety reasons is unfamiliar
to a world where you say,
okay, we have a powerful model.
Let's at least think about it.
Let's go through some process and you
think about the security community,
it took them a long time to design
responsible disclosure, right? You know,
you think about this question of,
well, I have a security exploit.
I sent it to the company. The company is
like, tries to prosecute me or just sit,
just ignores it. What do I do? Right?
And so you know, the alternatives of, Oh,
I just just always publish your exploits.
That doesn't seem good either. Right?
And so it really took a long
time and took this, this, uh,
it was bigger than any individual,
right?
It's really about building a whole
community that believed that, okay,
we'll have this process where you
sent it to the company. You know,
if they don't act in a certain time,
then you can go public and you're not a
bad person, you've done the right thing.
Um,
and I think that in AI,
part of the response to GPD to just
proves that we don't have any concept of
this. Um, so that's the
high level picture. Um,
and so I think that,
I think this was,
this was a really important move to make
and we could have maybe delayed it for
TBT three,
but I'm really glad we did it for gpt to,
and so now you look at gpt to itself and
you think about the substance of okay,
what are potential negative applications?
So you have this model that's been
trained on the Internet, which, you know,
it's also going to be a
bunch of very biased data. A
bunch of, you know, very, uh,
offensive content in there. Uh, and a,
you can ask it to generate content
for you on basically any topic, right?
You just give it a prompt and we'll just
start and start writing and our rights
content like you see on the Internet,
you know,
even down to like saying
advertisement in the middle of,
of some of it's generations. And, uh,
you think about the possibilities for
generating fake news or abusive content.
And you know, it's interesting seeing
what people have done with uh, you know,
we released a smaller version of gpt to,
and a that people have done
things like try to generate,
I take my own Facebook message history
and generate more Facebook messages like
me. Um, and uh,
people generating fake politician
I content or I, you know, there,
there's a bunch of things there were
nice to have to think is this going to be
good for the world?
There's the flip side,
which is I think that there's a lot of
awesome applications that we really want
to see,
like creative applications in terms of
if you have saifai authors that can work
with this tool and come up with cool
ideas like that seems, that seems awesome.
If we can write better Saifai through
the use of these tools and we've actually
had a bunch of people write into us
asking, Hey, can we use it for, you know,
a variety of different creative
applications. The positive,
I actually pretty easy to
imagine, uh, there if, you know,
the, the usual and a applications
are really interesting.
But let's go there.
It's kind of interesting to think
about a world where I look at Twitter
where that just fake news,
but smarter and smarter
bots being able to uh,
spread in an interesting
complex networking way in
information that just floods
out us regular human beings
with our original thoughts.
So
what are your views of this
world will gpt 20, right?
What do you, how do we
think about it? Again,
it's like one of those things about in
the fifties trying to describe the, uh,
the internet or the smartphone.
What do you think about that world,
the nature of information?
Do we add one possibility is that
we'll always try to design systems that
identify it, robot versus human,
and we'll do so successfully.
And so we will authenticate
that we're still human.
And the other world is
that we just accept the,
the fact that we're swimming in a sea of
fake news and just learn to swim there.
Well,
have you ever seen the uh,
pop popular meme of a, of a robot, uh,
with, with a physical, physical arm in
pen clicking the I am not a robot button.
Yeah.
I think,
I think that the truth is that that really
trying to distinguish between a robot
and human is a losing battle.
Ultimately you think it's a losing battle.
I think it's a losing battle ultimately.
Right?
I think that that is that
in terms of of the content,
in terms of the actions that you can take.
I mean think about how captures have gone,
right.
The capture is used to be a very nice,
simple, you just have this image.
All of our OCR is terrible. You put a
couple of of artifacts in it, you know,
humans are going to be able to tell what
it is an AI system wouldn't be able to
today like I can barely do captures.
Yeah,
and I think that this is just
kind of where we're going,
I think captures where we're a moment
in time thing and as AI system to become
more powerful that they're being human
capabilities that can be measured in a
very easy automated way that
the AI's will not be capable of.
I think that's just like, it's just
an increasingly hard technical battle,
but it's not that all hope is lost.
Right?
And you think about how do we already
authenticate ourselves, right? You know,
we have systems, we have social security
numbers. If you're in the US or you know,
you have, you have, uh, you know,
ways of identifying individual people
and having real world identity tied to
digital identities seems like
a step towards, you know,
authenticating the source of content
rather than the content itself.
Now there are problems with that.
How can you have privacy and anonymity
in a world where the only content you can
really trust is we're,
the only way you can trust content is
by looking at where it comes from. Um,
and so I think that building up
good reputation networks, maybe,
maybe one possible solution. But yeah,
I think that this, this question is,
is not an obvious one. And
I think that we, you know,
maybe sooner than we think we'll
be in a world where, you know,
today I often will read
a tweet and be like,
do I feel like real human
wrote this? Or, you know,
don't feel like it's just like genuine.
I feel like I can kind of judge
the content a little bit. Um,
and I think in the future it just won't
be the case. You look at, for example,
the FCC comments on net neutrality,
I came out later that millions of
those were autogenerated and that the
researchers were able to do various
statistical tick techniques to do that.
What do you do in a world where those
statistical techniques don't exist?
It's just impossible to tell the
difference between humans and AI highs.
And in fact, the, uh, the, the, the most
persuasive arguments are written by,
by Ai, all that stuff. It's
not saifai anymore. Okay.
Gpt to making a great argument for
why recycling is bad for the world.
You got to read that, you know, like,
Huh. You're right. Yeah. That's,
that's quite interesting.
I mean,
ultimately it boils down to the physical
world being the last frontier of
proving right.
You said like basically
networks of people,
humans vouching for humans in the physical
world and somehow the authentication
and ends there. I mean,
if I had to ask you,
you're way too eloquent for a human.
So if I had to ask you to authenticate,
like prove,
how do I know you're not a robot,
how do you know I'm not a robot?
I think that's so far we're,
we're
this in this space,
this conversation we just had,
the physical movements we did is the
biggest gap between us and AI systems as
the physical manipulation.
So maybe that's the last frontier.
Well, here's another question
is, is, you know, why, why is,
why is solving this problem important,
right?
Like what aspects are
really important to us?
I think that probably where we'll end
up is we'll hone in on what do we really
want out of knowing if we're talking to
a human. Um, and, uh, and I think that,
again,
this comes down to identity.
And so I think that that
the Internet of the future,
I expect to be one that we'll
have lots of agents out there, uh,
that will interact with you. But I think
that the question of is this, you know,
flush, real flesh and blood human,
or is this an automated system? Uh,
may actually just be less important.
Let's actually go there.
It's gpt to is impressive
and that's like a gpt 20.
Why is it so bad that all
my friends are gpt 20?
Why? Why is it so, why is it so important
on the intranet do you think, uh,
to interact with only human beings?
Why can't we live in a world where ideas
can come from models trained on human
data?
Yeah, I think this is, I think this is
actually a really interesting question.
This comes back to the how do you even
picture a world with some new technology,
right? And I think that the one thing that
I think is important is, is, you know,
good say honesty. Um, and I
think that if you have, you know,
almost in the Turing test style a
sense sense of, of, of technology,
you have ais that are pretending to be
humans and deceiving you. I think that is,
you know, that that feels
like a bad thing, right?
I think that it's really important that
we feel like we're in control of our
environment,
right?
That we understand who we're interacting
and if it's an AI or a human, um, that,
that that's not something that
we're being deceived about.
But I think that the flip side of can
I have as meaningful of an interaction
with an AI as I can with the human?
Uh,
well I actually think here you can turn
into Scifi and her I think is a great
example of asking this very question,
right?
One thing I really love about her is it
really starts out almost by asking how
meaningful our human virtual
relationships, right? And, uh,
and then you have a human who has
a relationship with an AI and, uh,
that you really start to
be drawn into that, right?
And that all of your emotional buttons
get triggered in the same way as if there
was a real human that was on
the other side of that phone.
And so I think that this is one way of
thinking about it is that I think that we
can have meaningful interactions
and that if there's a funny joke,
some sense it doesn't really matter
if it was written by a human or an AI,
but what you don't want and away where
I think we should really draw hard lines
is deception. Um, and I think that as long
as we're in a world where, you know, why,
why do we build AI systems at all,
right?
The reason we went to build
them is to enhance human lives,
to make humans be able to do more things,
to have human humans feel more fulfilled.
And if we can build AI systems that
do that, uh, you know, sign me up.
So the process of language modeling,
how far do you think it takes us? Let's
look a movie her. Do you think, uh,
uh, dialogue, natural
language conversation is
formulated by the Turing test,
for example.
Do you think that process could be
achieved through this kind of unsupervised
language modeling?
So I think the Turing test in its in
its real form isn't just about language,
right? It's really about reasoning to
write that to really pass the Turing test.
I should be able to teach calculus to
whoever's on the other side and have it
really understand calculus and be able to,
you know,
go in and solve new calculus problems.
And so I think that to
really solve the Turing test,
we need more than what we're
seeing with language models.
We need some way of
plugging in reasoning now,
how different will that be from what
we already do? That's an open question,
right?
It might be that we need some sequence
of totally radical new ideas or it might
be that we just need to kind of shape
our existing systems in a slightly
different way. But I think that in terms
of how far language model we'll go,
it's already gone way further than
many people would have expected. Right.
I think that things like,
and they think there's a lot of really
interesting angles to poke in terms of
how much does gpt to understand
physical world. Like, you know, you,
you read a little bit about
fire underwater, uh, in, in
Gbd too. So it's like, okay,
maybe it doesn't quite understand what
these things are. But at the same time,
I think that you also see various things
like smoke coming from flame and you
know, a bunch of these things
that Gbtq it has no body,
it has no physical experience,
it's just statically red data. Um,
and I think that,
I think that if the answer is like,
we don't know yet, um,
these questions though,
we're starting to be able to actually
ask them to physical systems that real
systems that exist and that's
very exciting. Do you think,
what's your intuition you
think if you just scale
language modeling, uh, like, uh,
significantly scale that reasoning
can emerge from the same exact mechanisms?
I think it's unlikely that if we just
scale GPD to that will have reasoning in
the full fledged way. And I think
that there's like, you know,
the type signatures a little bit wrong,
right?
Like there's something we do with
that we call thinking, right,
where we spend a lot of compute,
like a variable amount of compute
to get to better answers, right?
I think a little bit harder, I
get a better answer. And that,
that kind of type signature isn't
quite encoded in a Gbt, right?
Gbt will kind of like,
it spent a long time and it's like
evolutionary history baking and all this
information getting very,
very good at this predictive process.
And then at runtime I just kind
of do one Ford Pass and uh, and,
and be able to generate
stuff. And so, you know,
there might be small tweaks to what we
do in order to get the type signature
right. For example. Well, you know, it's
not really one for had passed. Right.
You know,
you generate some boy I symbol and so
maybe you generate like a whole sequence
of, of, of thoughts and you only keep
the last bit or something. Right. Um,
but I think that at the very least,
I would expect you have
to make changes like that.
Yeah. Yeah. Just exactly how we,
you said think is the process
of generating thought by
thought in the same kind
of way. Like you said, keep the last bit
the thing that we converge towards. Yup.
And I think there's, there's another
piece which is, which is interesting,
which is this out of distribution
generalization, right?
And they're like thinking somehow
that's, let's do that, right.
That we haven't experienced a thing.
And yet somehow we just kind of keep
refining our mental model of it. Um,
this is again,
something that feels tied to whatever
reasoning is and maybe it's a small tweak
to what we do, maybe as many ideas
and we'll take as many decades.
Yeah. So the, the assumption there,
a generalization out of distribution is
that it's possible to create new ideas,
the Po, you know, as possible that
nobody's ever created any new ideas.
And then with scaling Gpt to did gpt 20,
uh,
you would,
you would essentially generalize
to all possible thoughts I'll,
Siemens could have.
I think so, just to play
devil's advocate here, right?
I mean, how many, how many, uh,
new, new story ideas have we come up
with Shakespeare, right? Yeah, exactly.
It's just all different forms of
love and drama and so on. Okay.
Not sure if you read,
but
a lesson, a recent blog post
by rich Sutton. Yup. I have,
he basically says,
uh,
something that echoes some of the
ideas that you've been talking about,
which is a,
he says the biggest lesson that can be
read from so many years of AI research is
that general methods that leverage
computation are ultimately going to, uh,
ultimately went out. Uh,
do you agree with this?
So basically have an open the in general
about ideas that you're exploring about
coming up with methods or there's gpt
to modeling or whether it's a five
playing dota where a general method is
better than a more fine tuned expert
tuned
method. Yeah. So I think that, well,
one thing that I think was
really interesting about
the reaction to that blog
post was an audit.
People have read this as saying
that compute is all that matters.
And that's a very threatening idea.
Right.
And I don't think it's a true idea either.
Right?
It's very clear that we have algorithmic
ideas that have been very important for
making progress and to really build AGI.
You want to push as far as you can and
the computational scale and you want to
push as far as you can on human human
ingenuity. And so I think you need both.
But I think the way that you phrased the
question is actually very good, right?
That it's really about what kind
of ideas should we be striving for.
And absolutely, if you can find a
scalable idea, pour more computing power,
more data into it, it gets better. Like
that's, that's the real holy grail.
And so I think that, uh,
the, the, the answer to the
question, and I think it's yes.
Um,
that,
that that's really how we think about
it and that part of why we're excited
about the power of deep learning,
the potential for building Agi is because
we look at the systems that exist in
the most successful AI systems and
we realize that you scale those up,
they're going to work better.
And I think that that scalability is
something that really gives us hope for
being able to build
transformative systems.
So I'll tell you this, it
partially and emotional, you know,
a thing that response
that people often have,
this computer is so important for
state of the outperformance. You know,
individual developers,
maybe a 13 year olds sitting somewhere
in Kansas or something like that,
you know,
they're sitting,
they might not even have a GPU
and or may have a single GPU,
a 10 80 or something like that. And
there's this feeling like, well,
how can I possibly compete or contribute
to this world of AI if a scale is so
important? So if you can
comment on that. And in general,
do you think we need to also
in the future focus on, uh,
democratizing compute resources more,
more,
or as much as we
democratize the algorithms?
Well, so the way that I think about
it is that there's this space of,
of possible progress,
right?
There's a space of ideas and
sort of systems that will work,
that will move us forward.
And there's a portion of that space.
And to some extent,
increasingly significant portion of that
space that does just require massive
compute resources.
And for that that I think that the answer
is kind of clear that part of why we
have the structure that we do is because
we think it's really important to you
pushing the scale and to be, you know,
building these large clusters and systems.
But there's another part portion of the
space that isn't about the large scale
compute that are these ideas that,
and again,
I think that for the days to really
be impactful and really shine,
that they should be ideas that if you
scale them up would work way better than
they do at small scale.
Um,
but that you can discover them without
massive computational resources.
And if you look at the history of,
of recent developments,
you think about things like the Gan or
the VAE that these are ones that I think
you could come up with them
without having. And you know,
in practice people did come up with,
with them without having massive,
massive computational resources.
Right. I just talked to Ian Goodfellow.
But the thing is the initial Gan
produce pretty terrible results,
right?
So only because it wasn't a very specific,
it was only because they're smart enough
to know that this is quite surprising
him generated anything.
Did they know any,
do you see a world or is
that too optimistic and
dream or like to imagine that
the compute resources or something that's
owned by governments and provided a as
utility? Actually, someone sent
this, this question reminds me of,
of a blog post from one of my former
professors at Harvard. It's this guy map,
not Welsh, who was assistant professor.
I remember sitting in his tenure talk,
right? And, uh, you know that he
had literally just gotten tenure.
You went to Google for
the summer. Uh, and uh,
I then decided he wasn't going back to
academia and that kind of in his blog
posts,
he makes this point that look as a systems
researcher that I come up with these
cool system ideas, right? And I
kind of belittle a proof of concept.
And the best thing I can hope for is
that the people at Google or Yahoo,
which was around at the time,
we'll implement it and
actually make it work at scale.
That's like the dream for me,
right?
I built the little thing and they turned
into the big thing that's actually
working and a for him. He
said, I'm done with that.
I want to be the person who is, who's
actually doing building and deploying.
And I think that there's a
similar dichotomy here, right?
I think that there are people who've
really actually find value and I think it
is a valuable thing to do to be the
person who produces those ideas, right?
Who builds the proof of concept and yeah,
you don't get to generate the
coolest possible gang images,
but you invented the gown. Right?
Right. And so that there's, there's,
there's a real trade off there and I
think that that's a very personal choice,
but I think there's value in
both sides. Did you think, uh,
creating AGI something or some new models?
Uh,
would, we would see echoes of the
brilliance even at the prototype level.
So you would be able to
develop those ideas without
scale. The initial sow seeds.
Take a look at, you know, I always like
to look at examples that exist, right?
Look at real precedent.
And so take a look at the June,
2018 models that we released,
we scaled up to turn into gpt to,
and you can see that at small
scale, it set some records, right?
This was the original gpt. We actually
had some, some cool generations.
They weren't nearly as as, as amazing
and really stunning as the gpt to ones,
but it was promising.
It was interesting.
And so I think it is the case
that with a lot of these ideas,
do you see promise at small scale?
But there isn't an asterisk here,
a very big asterisk,
which is sometimes we see behaviors that
emerge that are qualitatively different
from anything we saw at small scale.
And that the original inventor of
whatever algorithm looks at and says,
I didn't think it could do that. Hmm.
This is what we saw in Dota, right?
So Ppo was, was created by John Coleman,
who's a researcher here. And, uh,
and with, with Dota, we basically just
ran PPO at massive, massive scale. And,
uh, you know, there's some tweaks in
the north star in order to make it work,
but fundamentally it's PPO with the core.
And we were able to get this
longterm planning these,
these behaviors to really play out on a
timescale that we just thought was not
possible. Um, and John looked
at that and it was like,
I didn't think it could do that.
That's what happens when you're at three
orders of magnitude more scale than
tested at. Yeah. But it still has the
same flavors of, uh, you know, uh,
and these echoes of the expected billions,
uh,
although I suspect with gpt
is scaled more and more,
you might get surprising things. Uh,
so yeah. Yeah, you're right. It's,
it's interesting that it's,
it is difficult to see how far an
idea we'll go when it's scaled.
It's an open question. Well,
so to that point with, with
Dota and PPO, look, I mean,
here's, here's a very concrete
one, right? It's like, um,
it's actually one thing that's very
surprising about Dota that I think people
don't really pay that much attention to
is the decree of generalization out of
distribution that happens,
right?
That you have this AI that's trained
against other bots for its entirety.
The entirety of its existence is, sorry to
take a step back. Can you, can you tell,
talk through is, you
know, a story of Dota,
uh,
story of uh,
leading up to opening I five and a that
passed and what was the process of self
plan?
So a lot of training on what is Dota Dota,
it's a complex video game.
And we started training,
we started trying to solve Dota because
we felt like this was a step towards the
real world relative to other games like
chess or go write those very Sri Board
Games where you just kind of have
this board of very discreet moves.
Dota starts to be much more continuous
time that you have this huge variety of
different actions that you
have a 45 minute game with
all these different units.
And,
uh,
it's got a lot of messiness to it that
really hasn't been captured by previous
games. And famously all of the hard
coated bots for Dota were terrible, right?
It's just impossible to write anything
good for it because it's so complex.
And so this seemed like a
really good place to push.
What's the state of the art
in reinforcement learning?
And so we started by focusing on the one
versus one version of the game and uh,
and,
and we're able to solve that.
We able to beat the world champions
and that the, the, the, the learning,
the skill curve was this
crazy exponential, right?
And it was like constantly we were just
scaling up that we were fixing bugs and
you know, that you look at the, at the
skill curve and it was really very,
very smooth one.
And so it's actually really interesting
to see how that like human iteration
loop yielded very steady
exponential progress. And a two one,
one side note. First of all, it's
an exceptionally popular video game.
The side effect is that there's a lot of
incredible human experts at that video.
Again, so the benchmark they are trying
to reach is very high. And the other,
can you talk about the approach that was
used initially and throughout training
these agents to play this game?
And so the approach that we used,
his self pay and so you have two
agents that don't know anything.
They battle each other,
they discover something a little bit
good and now they both know it and they
just get better and better
and better without bound.
And that's a really powerful idea,
right?
That we then went from the one versus
one version of the game and scaled up to
for five versus five,
right?
So you think about kind of like with
basketball where you have this like team
and you,
I need to do all this coordination
and we're able to push the same idea,
the same self play, uh, to, to, to,
to really get to the professional level
at the full five versus five version of
the game. And, uh, and, and,
and the things I think are
really interesting here is
that these agents in some
ways, they're almost like an
insect like intelligence, right?
Where they have a lot in common with
how an insect is trained, right.
Insect kind of lives in this environment
for a very long time. Or you know, the,
the ancestors of this insect have been
around for a long time and had a lot of
experience. It gets baked into,
into, into this agent. And you know,
it's not really smart in
the sense of a human right.
It's not able to go in and learn calculus,
but able to navigate it's environment
extremely well and is able to handle
unexpected things in the environment
that's never seen before pretty well. Um,
and we see the same sort of thing
with our dough to bots, right?
That they're able to, within this game,
they're able to play against humans,
which is something that never existed
in its evolutionary environment.
Totally different play styles
from humans versus bots.
And yet it's able to
handle it extremely well.
And that's something that I think was
very surprising to us with something that
doesn't really emerge from what we've
seen with PPO at smaller scale or in the
kind of scale we running this
stuff out was uh, you know,
I could take 100,000 CPU cores running
with like hundreds of Gpu. Yes. Uh,
it was probably about, uh, you know,
like something like hundreds of of years
of experience going into this bought
every single real day.
And so that scale is massive and we
start to see very different kinds of
behaviors out of the algorithms
that we all know. And love.
Dora you mentioned beat
the world expert One v One,
and then, uh, we, you, uh,
didn't, weren't able to win five,
the five this year at the, at the
best players in the world. Uh,
so what's, what's the
comeback story? What's,
first of all I'll talk through that does
exceptionally exciting event and uh,
what's, what's the, the following months
and this year look like? Yeah, yeah.
One thing that's interesting is that, uh,
you know, we lose all the time. All right.
So the DOTA team at open the eye,
we w we played against better
players than our system all the time,
or at least we used to write
like, you know, the, the, the,
the first time we lost publicly was we
went up on stage at the international and
we played against some of the
best teams in the world. Um,
and we ended up losing both games, but we
give them a run for their money, right?
The both games were kind of 30 minutes,
25 minutes, and they went back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth.
And so I think that really shows that
we're at the professional level. Um,
and that kind of looking at those games,
we think that the coin could have gone
a different direction and we could of
could of had some wins and thought that
was actually very encouraging for us. Um,
and you know, it's interesting because
the international, was that a fixed time?
All right.
So we,
we knew exactly what day we were going
to be playing and we pushed as far as we
could, as fast as we could.
Yeah. Two weeks later,
we had a bot that had an 80% win rate
versus the one that played at Tci. Um,
so the march of progress, uh, you know,
that you should think of it as a
snapshot rather than as an end state. Um,
and so in fact, we'll, we'll be announcing
our, uh, our, our finals pretty soon.
I actually think that, uh, we'll
announce our final match. I,
prior to this podcast being released. So
there should be, uh, we'll be playing.
Well, you're playing against the
world champions and you know,
for us it's really less about like the,
the way that we think about what's
upcoming is the final milestone,
the file competitive milestone
for the project, right.
That our goal in all of this isn't
really about beating humans at Dota.
Our goal is to push the state of
the art in reinforcement learning.
And we've done that,
right?
And we've actually learned a lot from
our system and that we have, I, you know,
I think a lot of exciting next steps
that we want to take. And so, you know,
of the final showcase of what we built,
we're going to do this match. Um,
but for us it's not really the success or
failure, um, to see, you know, do, do, do,
do we have the coin flip go in our
direction or against [inaudible]
where do you see the field of deep
learning heading in the next few years?
Uh, where do you see the work
in reinforcement learning,
perhaps hiding and uh,
more specifically with open AI,
all the exciting projects that
you're working on. What is 2019?
Hold for you? Massive scale scale. I will
put an asterisk on that and just say,
you know, I think that it's about
ideas plus scale. You need both.
So that's a really good point.
So the question in terms of ideas,
you have a lot of projects that are
exploring different areas of intelligence.
And a, the question is, when
you, when you think of scale,
do you think about growing scale,
those individual projects or do you
think about adding new projects and uh,
sorry if you were thinking of adding
new projects or if you look at the past,
what's the process of coming up
with new projects, new ideas? Yup.
Uh, so we really have a life
cycle of project here. Uh,
so we start with a few people just working
on a small scale idea and language is
actually a very good example of
this. That it was really, you know,
one person here who was pushing on
language for a long time. I mean,
then you get signs of life, right? And so
this is like, let's say a, you know, with,
with the original gpt, we had something
that was interesting and we said, okay,
it's time to scale this, right?
It's time to put more people on it,
put more computational
resources behind it. And uh,
and then we just kind of keep
pushing and keep pushing.
And the end state is something that looks
like Dota or robotics where you have a
large team of,
you know,
10 or 15 people that are running things
at very large scale and that you're able
to really have material engineering,
uh, and, and, uh, and, and you know,
sort of machine learning science coming
together to make systems that work and
get material results that just would
have been impossible otherwise. Um,
so we do that whole lifecycle. We've
done it a number of times, uh, you know,
typically end to end. It's
probably two, uh, two years or
so, a to do it. I, you know,
if the organization's been
around for three years,
so maybe we'll find that we also
have longer life cycle projects. Um,
but you know, we, we uh, uh, we'll
work up to those. We have, uh, so,
so one,
one team that we were actually just
starting Ilien and I are kicking off a new
team called the reasoning team and that
this is to really try to tackle how do
you get neural networks to reason and,
uh,
we think that this will
be a long term project.
It's one that we're very excited
about. Uh, in terms of reasoning,
super exciting topic. What do
you, what kind of benchmarks,
uh, what kind of tests of reasoning
do you envision? What would,
if you set back with whatever drink and
you will be impressed that this system
is able to do something, what would
that look like? Are improving,
they are improving.
So some kind of logic and especially in
mathematical logic. I think so. Right.
And I think that there's,
there's,
there's kind of other problems that are
dual to theorem improving in particular.
Um, you know, you think
about, uh, programming,
I think about even like
security analysis of,
of code that these all kind of capture
the same sorts of core reasoning and,
and being able to do some out
of distribution generalization,
it would be quite exciting if open AI
reasoning team was able to prove that p
equals NP.
That'd be very nice.
Uh, it'd be very, very, very
exciting, especially if it
turns out the people's NP.
That'll be interesting
to maybe, uh, it just,
it would be a ironic
and humorous. Yup. Uh,
so what problem
stands out to you as, uh, the
most, uh, exciting and challenging,
impactful to the work for
us as a community in general
and for open AI and this
year you mentioned reasoning. I think
that's, that's a heck of a problem.
Yeah. So I think reasoning,
it's an important one.
I think it's going to be hard to get good
results in 2019. Um, you know, again,
just like we think about the
life cycle, it takes time. Um,
I think for 2019 language model that
seems to be kind of on that ramp, right?
It's at the point that we
have a technique that works.
We want to scale a hundred x thousand
x, see what happens. Awesome.
Do you think we're living in a
simulation? Uh, I think it's,
I think it's hard to have a, a
real opinion about it. I, you know,
it's actually interesting,
I separate out things that I think can
have like yield materially different
predictions about the world from
ones that are just kind of fun,
fun to speculate about. And I kind
of view simulation. It's more like,
is there a flying teapot between
Mars and Jupiter? Like maybe,
but it's a little bit hard to know
what that would mean for my life.
So there is some something
actionable.
So some of the best work opening has
done is in the field of reinforcement
learning and some of the
success of reinforcement
learning come from being able
to simulate the problem you try to solve.
So it,
do you have a hope for reinforcement
for the future of reinforcement learning
and for the future of simulation,
like whether it's, we're talking
about autonomous vehicles
or any kind of system,
do you see that scaling to where
we'll be able to simulate systems and,
and hence be able to create a simulator
that echoes our real world and uh,
proving once and for all,
even though you're denying it,
that we're living in a simulation.
Two separate questions,
right? So, you know, kind of,
kind of with the core there of like, can
we use simulation for self driving cars?
Uh, take a look at our
robotic system dactyl right.
That was trained in simulation
using the DOTA system in fact,
and it transfers to a physical robot.
And I think everyone looks at our
dota system, they're like, okay,
it's just a game. How are you ever
going to escape to the real world?
And the answer as well. We did it with a
physical robot that no one can program.
And so I think the answer is simulation
goes a lot further than you think.
If you apply the right techniques to
it. Now there's a question of, you know,
are the beings in that simulation can
not gonna wake up and have consciousness.
Um, I think that one seems a lot, lot
harder to, to again, reason about,
I think that, you know, you really
should think about like, we're,
we're exactly just human consciousness
come from in our own self awareness.
And you know,
is it just that like once you have
like a complicated enough neural net,
you have to worry about the agents
feeling pain. Um, and uh, you know,
I think there's like
interesting speculation to do
there, but uh, but you know,
again, I think it's, it's a
little bit hard to know for sure.
Well, let me just keep with the
speculation. Do you think, uh,
to create intelligence,
general intelligence,
you need one consciousness and to a body,
do you think any of those elements
are needed or as intelligence,
something that's that sort
of fog and all to those?
I'll stick to the, the kind of like the,
the, the non grand answer first, right?
So the non grand answer is
just to look at, you know,
what are we already making work?
You'll get GPD too.
A lot of people would have said that
to even get these kinds of results,
you need real world experience.
You need a body unique grounding.
How are you supposed to reason
about any of these things?
How are you supposed to like even kind
of know about smoke and fire and those
things if you've never experienced them.
And GPD two shows that you can actually
go way further than that kind of
reasoning would predict.
So I think that the,
in terms of do we need consciousness,
do we need a body?
It seems the answer is probably not right.
That we could probably just continue
to push kind of the systems we have.
They already feel general,
um,
they're not as competent or as general
or able to learn as quickly as an AGI
would,
but you know,
there are at least like kind of Prodo Agi
in some way and they don't need any of
those things. Now, now let's move to
the grand answer, which is, you know,
if our, our neural nets, nets
conscious already, would we ever know,
how can we tell right here? Here's where
the speculation starts to become, become,
you know,
at least interesting or fun and maybe
a little bit disturbing it depending on
where you take it. But it certainly
seems that when we think about animals,
that there's some continuum
of, of, of consciousness.
You know, my cat I think is,
uh, is conscious in some way, right? I,
you know, not as conscious as a human.
And you could imagine that you could
build a little consciousness meter, right?
You pointed a cat, it gives you a little
reading, putting out a human. Again,
it gives you much bigger reading.
What would happen if he appointed one
of those at a doughnut neural net?
And if you're training in this massive
simulation, do the neural nets feel pain?
You know,
it becomes pretty hard to know that the
answer is no and it becomes pretty hard
too to really think about what that
would mean if the answer were yes.
And it's very possible,
you know, for example,
you could imagine that maybe the reason
that humans are have consciousness is
because it's a, it's a convenient
computational shortcut, right?
If you think about it, if you have
a being that wants to avoid pain,
which seems pretty important to
survive in this environment, um,
and wants to like, you know, eat food, um,
then that maybe the best way of doing it
is to have it being of it's conscious,
right? That, you know, in order
to succeed in the environment,
you need to have those properties and
how he's supposed to implement them.
And maybe this, this consciousness
is way of doing that. If that's true,
then actually maybe we should expect
that really competent reinforcement
learning agents. We'll also have
consciousness, but you know,
it's a big enough and I think there are
a lot of other arguments that can make
another directions.
And
I think that's a really interesting
idea that even gpt to has some degree of
consciousness and it's something,
uh,
is actually not as crazy to think of all
it's useful to think about as we think
about what it means to create intelligence
of a dog intelligence of a cat and
the intelligence of human. So
last question. Do you think
we will
or fall in love like in the movie her
with an artificial intelligence system or
an artificial intelligence system
falling in love with a human?
I hope so.
If there's any better way to
end it is on a love. So, Greg,
thanks so much for talking today.
Thank you for having me.